[Music]  road rage appeared to get the better of  Jenelle Evans on Teen Mom 2 after  battling a truck on the highway  [Music]  the 26 year old appeared to pull a  handgun out of her driver's side door  before following the other driver home  leading it to a tense standoff  [Music]  Janell eventually left the man's house  but was then pulled over by a police  officer after the episode aired fans  called Janelle out on line for allegedly  acting so recklessly with her son in the  car he slammed into us hit mommy just  pulled his gun not good night the guy  and then he said you better not shoot  the reality star later denied ever  pulling out her firearm though she has  not addressed the backlash  [Music]